is time for some blitz I just joined the
blitz shield arena this is a monthly
tournament and the winner gets the
unique shield trophy which I'm not going
to win this is a six hour long events
I'm joining with about an hour and 45
minutes left but hopefully I'll play
some decent quality chests maybe I can
break 2300 I'll play a two Knights
attack someone one of my favorite
openings to teach against the French so
play is pretty fluid for whites and the
point of this opening is white doesn't
really reinforce the center too much at
least with the pawns it's more about
piece play and there's a few traps that
black can fall into one of the traps is
taking on b2 yeah this is already very
good for white
I've had this multiple times before
Knight d5 not only it tries to trap the
queen but threatens Knight c7 if black
castles there's a great gift with bishop
take h7 so life is good
hey it's a sabzi nation chess 13 months
in a row most loyal most longtime
subscriber welcome back things e
nation's only person who's been a sub
for over a year I've had this position
at least a few times on stream over the
last year
usually people Castle this guy is
probably realizing castling walks into
Bishop takes h7 but the other threat is
I think something like Bishop d2 and key
e7 is kind of funny the Bishop g2 maybe
it's Queen e2 first
yeah Queen e2 threatening rook f b1
reinforcing a 5
ah Queen before maybe the Queen's
escaping Bishop g5 there's some funny
line Bishop g5 f6 some line where I
throw in Knight c7 and then win d5 let's
start with Bishop g5 because if f6 I can
take and then I'll play Knight c7 this
is just a massive fork I'm threatening
this this and then this Queen takes c6
is actually made in two threats
unless maybe he can play King d8 but
okay there's so many threats in the
position between his rook his King his
Queen that defends something but not
everything because I can take twice that
pawn is pinned now I'm still threatening
this I'm threatening this threatening
this let's just win oh I can take the
other route - I can take either rook or
I can take the Queen is there any mating
ideas Queen g7 he just resigned
okay that was a nice finish sixteen
moves that's one of the reasons why I
teach this this - Knights attack against
a French it's so venomous like so many
players will play Queen b6 not realizing
what they're walking into
so maybe I'll have to do like a whole
whole video just covering that opening
because there's some other traps too but
for now we're gonna move on play another
another blitz game let's play e4 again
mmm would be hard to mess that moving
the King on the first move hello -
people in the chats is this a free pawn
looks like a free pawn maybe he wants
the scholars meet me he's gonna play
like Queen yeah he's gonna say Queen
Queen f6 or Queen h4 d 4 is probably
most principled defending attacking
covering F to be five so if I take the
bishop he takes a night what does be
five though can just take the pawn
now at sevens attacks I don't want to be
mean but I feel like this guy's playing
much below his rating but as I've
learned in the past I could never let my
guard down
do I fork maybe I fork because that rook
is just trapped is this gonna be another
quick win
hello to car Mar and hello to everyone
else I didn't say hello to Raphael Ito a
bikes so I can okay I can play Queen f3
it's a fork so many black pieces are
loose I can take the knight for free
this feels like Christmas just so many
things
what's Castle King safety first
now I'm attacking the bishop he's
attacking my queen let's just trade
Queens I just wanna like prompt
resignation or maybe all mates
maybe rook e8 will be mates or if he
plays g6 Bishop h6 is mates there we go
okay that was nice so a couple quick
games so far
want to break into the top thousand over
2300 people playing this tournament
Nathan F Nathan F is back with a tier 3
sub one of my only tier 3 subscribers
Nathan same tog
at first I thought that was pug got
excited nine months in a row almost
catching up to znation so I this is my
third game in a row is white and try and
keep up though the momentum two days
till Carlsen Cara Juana
that's true Ashley today's today's
Wednesday wait two days until I fly to
London okay so I have a Grand Prix this
guy logged in is a screen can never tell
if it's green or no lost connection now
he's back
so I'm just gonna do typical grand-prix
stuff Queen h4 f5 Bishop h6 don't be
aggressive at six Wow look at these
pawns five in a row oh now I don't know
if I want to go for an attack maybe I'll
play slightly more positionally let's
start with this I just want to see what
he's up to
if he's not up to anything I'll just
play kind of slow improving this could
maybe no I play rook b1 first
b3 f5 maybe I should play rugby one
first
usually the the positional plan is stuff
like this where it just restricts the
queenside is there an actual Grand Prix
coming up I mean there's a Grand Prix
opening and then there's a Grand Prix
like fidei events rook d7 let's do this
just a matter of slow play usually if
black plays this I just ignore it and I
continue with my plans because it's
slightly weakening to c5 okay so he
plays out 595 is a made threats but then
h6 so let's just keep keep plugging away
my plans I have no idea who's gonna win
I think Carlsen is probably a slight
favorites but I'm rooting for Fabiano
howdy 5 so there's a lot of pressure now
I don't know if Locke has any threats
but I'm tempted to just play this close
things down because he has a bishop pair
when the opponent has a bishop pair if
we can close apposition down the bishops
both bishops are not so happy and the
Knights are happier like this knight can
do stuff this Mike can do stuff ooh
ok so this is kind of what I was waiting
for because now it's it's gonna be
purely positional look at this pawn I
don't think I was about to say I don't
think he could defend it but Queen d5
proves me wrong I think the goal is to
bring this Bishop to a3
but there's no rush let's play this
first toilet noggin saying hello toilet
noggin usually says Heil
this time he's just using a normal
greeting suspicious oh the problem with
box position like there's so little
active play there's no great pawn breaks
a c4 can't be played any a pawn push
can't really do anything Knight g5 is a
fork
another nice game is that three games in
a row less than 20 moves
yeah that's three games in a row the
first game was 16 news last two games
where 18 moves it's nice to be white
like a free game I broke into the top
thousand I'm gonna try and keep up the
aggressive openings it's called the
shield arena because the winner of the
tournament gets a shield and they keep
the shield until the next shield arena
ocala berserk because he's busy working
let's play over versus London this time
I'll be a bit more solid than usual but
I'll still be attempting to be
aggressive there's a squirrel on the
roof the other day I saw there is a
squirrel on my neighbor's roof jumped
off the roof and just like landed on the
ground it was like a good 15-foot drop
and I just kept running okay let's not
get distracted let's play h6 this is
another kind of slow play position
because White's not doing much I mean
White's just trying to move quickly and
flag me so I have to be slightly aware
I'm just looking to gain space improve
the pieces maybe do something on the
queenside I won Connect four
maybe I can do this create some weakness
I'm gonna put the Queen here just a more
useful square covering the night
preparing to castle let's take mm-hmm
okay so now I have some space and the
goal is still probably to focus on the
Queen side but I could look to play on
the Kings side too I don't know what to
do but I have to move quickly let's play
let's play this someday I might want to
break with c4
I think one goal is to control the f4
square because this isn't White's main
pawn move and if I can stop him from
playing f4 it'll be annoying for him I
take on g3 win three pawns probably
another good idea I'm just gonna go for
more control over f4 maybe I'll play f5
myself I put the Queen on b7 pin the e
pawn play a five put the rook back on f8
he's attacking the pawn maybe I can play
h5 always play off six always play g6
this bishops kind of sad now wasn't my
intention doing that let's put the Queen
here I still want to play out five if he
plays Queen age six I can probably play
Knight g5 everything's covered kind of I
want to play nine f7 kick the Queen away
I should also maybe move a bit more
quickly
wait the queen is trapped cos he played
f4 Queen has no escape
that's nice so he's gonna win something
for it but no I'm up a queen and if he
takes f6 I just want to trade also a
cold player thanks for this up I don't
think I thanked you four times in a row
four months in a row g5 and it's play 95
first
okay let's not get careless I just have
to play quick and play solid and win win
anything that's free that's a good move
I play this ooh
the rook is defending I was a terrible
move but he didn't see it
okay well the my Brook was hanging to
okay this is turning into a fight but
I'm still up a queen for a rook and
minor piece Bishop D or Bishop c4 will
come and we'll trade I'll get some
attack knife at five will come or he'll
just flag okay not the cleanest
conversion but conversion nonetheless I
was a much longer game than the first
three the Queen trap was quite helpful
my final move was nine five five fine
gold would be happy
so I'm top six hundred clean score first
place has a hundred fifty three points
that's hard to catch up to but I'll try
my best
I'm not gonna be zerk only if my
opponent berserks while I berserk back
can you play English or Sicilian I can
pre move c5 and see what happens
okay we have a Sicilian I'll play the UM
I'll play the pin variation not so
useful effective opening against low
rated players pin variations dubious at
higher levels but while the players just
don't know how to react to this and then
they start thinking at Bishop g5 it's
like Queen c7 applying a media pressure
on pinning the night so the pawn is
attacked if you take some have six maybe
I just take on c3 Queen c7 is very
typical move and these these lines Queen
e5 looks attractive attacking everything
things could get weird though the very
least I'm threatening Queen takes e4 so
if he takes on f6 maybe I could take
with check the one problem is there's
Knight c7 in the end the Queen takes e4
Queen e2 we trade I take back on f6 and
then there's 97 so I guess I don't want
a pawn but e4 still attacked we'll see
if he sees it
I'm also threatening a6 probably remove
the night then maybe win c3 I also want
to go for like maybe i5 ideas or d5 I
don't know
so he's still thinking I'm expecting
something like this and then probably a
six she a six is winning material I was
thinking he has f4o he plays a three
this is calculated light still trapped
maybe just Bishop c5 Bishop c5 yeah the
night's still trapped near von Raymond
yeah I got I got the email I've been so
bogged down with messages lately there's
like a whole backlog I will say my
schedule is so hectic but I'm still
going through them all probably reply by
like tonight or tomorrow it should be
six
my still trapped I might continue as a
counter-attack with my day four and then
at the very least I can take on f2
wait let's go got weird 9 9 84 Bishop
takes f2 no King takes f2 pawn takes b5
and the Knight b6 hmm so maybe I played
Bishop to Yates it's such a sad looking
move but a white still in the
predicament because if you play as might
be c3 I have B 5 I still want to win the
Knight f4 what does this variation Queen
D for such a weird variation like we
keep counter punching each other but I
think I'm getting the last laugh or the
last punch
because there's no oh is there a
counter-attack you complain 92 what is
this
oh he takes them b5 okay this is nice
now I think 92 would have saved him mmm
really tempted to take on the affor and
play Bishop b6 let's do it those lips
will be powerful
there
the idea is now he has to play b5 I play
Bishop e7 and threatening this and then
this okay hey another game less than 20
moves I think I've played humming game
so I played I played five games so far
and four of them have been wins less
than 20 moves zalem Bora thanks for the
message I don't think I have too many
Iraqi viewers so welcome I wanted to ask
is there anyone from Africa watching
anyone from Africa or Southeast Asia
because I'm going to both of those
places like the next few months I'm
curious about the the chess scenes
because Europe has a good chess scene
but other places I'm not so sure of so
now I'm playing another opening opening
trick see what happens
yeah III mean I could be zerk but well I
beserk sometimes I forget that I Berk I
get along one time and that's where bad
things happen I'm just trying to break
2300 and not embarrass myself and also
when I have more time it's easier to
explain things sometimes it's not about
who he's falling for a trap I played
this line a few months ago against John
Bartholomew and he fell for the same
thing it was during one of his his chest
calm streams the problem for lack okay
hole likely take on f7 maybe he wants
there's three legal moves here okay so
he takes yeah the problem for black is
that the Queen's are now aligned and
white will likely win a queen like if
gee 696 check I win the Queen
if King e6 94 check and I win a queen if
King f6 I won't win a queen but I'll
still have a massive attack
so there's been some successful openings
today doesn't happen this uh like this
consistently so ki6 trying to escape I'm
still winning a queen
it's thinking about pre moving yeah it
makes sense to pre move hey nine move
game that's the shortest game of today
back to tournament yeah the average
length of my white games so far have
been like 15 moves deadly opening traps
so I'm top top 350 21 points only need
like 140 more points to to catch up to
first okay new game I'm black I'm not
accepting challenges if you want to play
me you can join this tournament and
you'll have like a 1 in 2300 chance of
playing me let's play knight c6 I found
this to be an aggressive response to
Knight of 3 maybe not the most high
level response but the idea is to play
e5 and then what what what what he wants
to play the bond cloud what is this how
do i punish him I want to punish him to
the maximum efore immediately let's play
d5 ok this is this is bogus he's gonna
play King c3 where is my mate Queen
Queen f6 as a move Bishop b4 as a move
maybe Bishop Bishop before I'm taking
this seriously I should be for thinking
about d4 first now let's just take the
knight first because now d4 he won't be
able to take with this Knight now 95
people these days
the c5 gonna be mate that was nice this
actually reminds me of something I've
seen before well let me give up a puzzle
just a funny like brainteaser puzzle for
the viewers let's go back to the
starting position so the puzzle goes
like this white gets to make seven moves
in a row from move one black makes one
move and it's checkmate now I'm gonna go
ahead and show the solution and I'll
probably post this on youtube later so
if you're watching on YouTube feel free
to pause the video and try and figure
out the solution white makes seven moves
from starting position black makes one
move and it's mate in one
the solution is d3 King walks one two
three four wait D three was one so
that's five moves and then white plays
d4 and a four and then black plays c6
meet so that kind of reminded me of this
sort of meets the discovered check with
the pawn that was eight moves that's my
shortness game so far back to
tournaments top 300 now
yeah that's how you recruit refute
whatever opening that was not a
difficult opening to refute was that all
theory maybe that was all theory I don't
know so I have 25 points ok let's play
I'm gonna be aggressive I just want to
continue the opening momentum Center
fork trick
yeah the student other day who's saying
that's boring playing like these
symmetrical four Knights openings but
the the Center for trick is essentially
the solution to to all the boredom okay
this feels like a Halloween gambit where
I haven't I haven't sacrificed material
no I just want to I want an artificial
castle and then control the F file he
wants the castle okay well both castle
ooh
one passant or Bishop don't know if I
want to give up my e pawn she probably
played Bishop d6 mmm but then queen h5
yeah I think I'll take after Queen takes
King g8 and I'm attacking f2 I have 95
ideas like 95 Knight g4 can be strong I
still have some Center Knight g4
immediately
maybe c6 first so conflicted let's play
c6 first Knight g4 and Queen h4
well maybe come someday yeah like right
now
c3 is kind of slow now the queen is not
having access to the the third drink and
there's three attackers on f2 yeah the
best player the best player I'd beam
I mean online it was Carlsen if you can
count that as a real game in a
tournament I beat Ivana Savitch who's I
believe the top player from Serbia he
was ranked maybe a hundred in the world
when I play them
okay so I'm turning mate it's really
only one move four lights which is not
nine of three so to say the one move was
a ch3 okay he just resigns yeah I wasn't
actually sure what to do after a ch3
probably just take on f2 and then take
here and then we trade on that fade up
upon okay that was another 16 move game
so many miniatures
I think I'm tempted to just end
everything right here upload upload this
to YouTube and just call it like chess
miniatures how to trap your opponent in
the opening but not all my games have
been traps like it's just a lot of early
blunders and some long cloud my moves
zero-one thanks for the Sun 2 months in
a row Wow all the subscribers so far
have been subbing for multiple months in
a row thanks guys okay he's buzzer
keying all beserk back I'll have a
faster game let's play the same opening
I played in the first game g6 he wants
to play a hippo h4 is a quickest way to
attack now h5 prevents me from playing
h5 but it is a bit weakening to the g5
Square let's just continue development
at some point I might want to play e5
but for now I just want to play
restrictively I'm very tempted to play
Queen off four let's do it
while castling right into my attack I'm
not gonna hold back
I just want to control this square and
also now I have the D file Wow 95 so the
Knights I mean the Queen can be taken at
the very least I can win upon I don't
want to win more than upon hmm I take oh
wait we we double berserk
I shouldn't move quicker well maybe I'm
winning two pawns yeah it's this is not
the most exciting variation because we
trade Queens but I mean I'm winning two
pawns I'll play like Bishop III next or
a5 next expecting rook the eights
oooh figure out about that it's play
Bishop e2 I'm losing another pond am i
doing he doesn't take it though okay so
now I'm up relatively clean pawn if he
takes on that three I probably take with
pawn I just have to move quicker play a5
rely on instincts what's up comrade
how's it going
he's forking me oh let's defend stuff I
mean he could take on b2 and then
materials equal but then
at least we'll be easier to play and I
have a passed pawn here and I see pawn
is a passed pawn so if we trade stuff on
me to play rugby one okay nevermind oh
now I just want to play a B 3 C 4 well I
come today I might come by once it's 251
I'll decide in like 10 or 15 minutes is
there a meeting today if if people are
meeting I'll come by P 393 let's play C
3 Karma are 100 bits
thanks Karma what's up super major pain
I should probably stop looking at the
chats and focus on not flagging
even though I want to read all of these
these nice comments okay let's move
quicker keep the time advantage activate
the rook what works e6 could be blunder
Asst just double up slowly
mmm that's a free rook
I'm gonna sack the rook back because I
think I'm meeting a g8 he could have
taken the g5 on
it wouldn't be mates but okay time is a
factor let's go back I don't think we've
gone to the point where we need emote
only mode if it gets to that point maybe
all points and mods 9 f6 let's play
let's play this line I'm expecting d4
yeah this is a fun variation
please take on b2 okay
please take on anyone let's get four
Queens on the board this is one of the
few openings in chess where you can have
four Queens on the board by move seven
Oh
what a buzzkill it's so annoying
I mean objectively this is probably a
better line for luck but come on I was
hoping to have some fun let's play
Bishop Bishop e5 does that work there
should be five Bishop d7 queen g4 Queen
a5 it gets complicated oh let's just
play it anyway I will play Knight of
three we're gonna have some boring end
game probably have to play c3
my kind I play d5 probably not I might
end up losing a pawn then it's gonna be
annoying now he's playing well
castling we take a bunch of times maybe
I'll have some comp blacks winning upon
here but I'll have some open c-file
half-open be file stick with bishop
throw in the check okay it's gonna be a
fights pawns don't tell the whole story
because it comes down to who attacks
better and defends better f-7s attacked
that was a good move
maybe rook here threatening probably
threatening Knight takes e5 so Knight
takes e5 gets weird I think it's okay
though
Queen h3 would be a great gift wait I'm
actually I might just be winning here
for our knight c6 is a major threat if
Queen d5 I play knight c6 trade Queens
and then take on d4 this could be ending
unexpectedly I might be overlooking
something though like the targeting of
this King side is slightly scary given
that both f2 and g2 are only defended by
my king but I don't see anything for
black like this is a mate threat and
this is a main threat but neither of
those moves really work I don't think
sacrifices work either
Sarah nilly oh thanks for the bits so I
assume I can just capture and if Queen
f5 I play Knight f3
I mean maybe I'll go crazy and take on
g2 but I'll still find some shelter
hopefully
wait you sent me a message what where
did you send me a message was an email
or text or leech us so I don't see any
messages wait I'll meet us
[Music]
when did you send it because I don't
think I received it if you'd give
donations and my king will have shelter
it's a great comment pretty sure I can
build a shelter without donations okay
so now I'm just up a piece are there any
threats I just focus on attacking
I mean rook takes g2 could be a little
bit annoying
just looking for some simple move maybe
you just ripped you too
never hurts to prepare the double-up
this is probably going to be my last
game unfortunately I honestly was not
planning to stream today I was planning
to spend the whole day at Starbucks but
then I realized I forgot my charger and
my battery was just low
okay so g2 is attacked
so maybe just g3
how's that Starbucks earlier was the
most embarrassing thing that ever
happened to me like I got my I got my
London Fog which has recently become my
my favorite drink on top of my favorite
opening and then I got a sandwich so
before having the London Fog I had my
sandwich so I got half hour after I was
sitting there the London Fog it was
still completely full I went to get like
a napkin or something and my table was
wobbly when I got up the table was
wobbly enough it just knocked over the
drink and it spilled everywhere luckily
it did not get on my laptop but it was
all over the floor and it was like a
packed Starbucks - I felt so bad but the
barista was so nice cleaned it up gave
me another drink for free
let's try and convert this before I flag
I just want to play this
or do i maybe I can profit it with this
no I'm actually threatening force meets
rooks e6 is expected
Roxy six Rosie aids betrayed King c7
Queen d2
I mean everything is pretty much winning
as long as I don't blunder or flag let's
just trade Queens gonna be super boring
can I go for some mates check check
check
threatening meets who's going to take on
you too
I'm looking for mates but I'll be using
a flag first
I prepared night b8 mates okay that was
a slow finish but I finished nonetheless
I'm sure I had other options there why
don't I take on f7 was a7 hanging 7 was
hanging yeah Queen digs f7 would have
been very fine move I guess it would
have opened up a file for black but I
mean when you're up a piece there's so
many things you can do to win anyway
yeah that game could have been a lot
more exciting if you only taken promoted
to a queen how many times does this
happen only chess I play them I played
this before
I've had games in the past where like
Bach takes on the a2 I take on age seven
and black makes another queen and white
makes another queen it's pretty fun
anyway um I gotta take off I have so
much to do I'm leaving the country in
two days I have to pack have to buy
stuff I have to respond to messages but
thanks guys for watching I'll be back in
the future
my next stream might be in London I'm
hoping to do some like collaborations
there's going to be a lot of a lot of
famous people in London so we'll see
what happens but yeah thanks again and
I'll see you guys in the future